you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens what's up everybody we're
live at e3 2016 on the game spot co-op
station how are you audience whoa this
one guy with the camera refuses to clap
that guy just did this I don't think
that was helpful to the club I want to
be host Greg Miller from kind of funny
alongside Tim Geddes provided bunny and
ladies and gentlemen murs whoo very bad
ah there we go strange music yes holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] Wow believe we're sitting
here hanging out murder all day haha
first I the story with you goes like
this in me hard time to worry you don't
love stories i know and i'll go tell me
so we were down at momo con in atlanta
right I saw o tex got a show I love tech
nine of course I'm gonna go see a tec-9
show we walked in and then Tim over here
saw the MERS poster and he goes oh [ __ ]
mercy far strange music now and I was
like I don't know who's worse and then
you thought and you killed it and I
bought the album right there took a
photo with you to meet and greet and
then I got on the plane I was like this
guy's amazing i kept telling tina of it
big fan thank you to my one my favorite
shirts growing up was the merge is
better than your favorite rapper it's
very true to this day not as good as
this shirt donkey kong but not you know
I've got grown a little bit but you love
your music love you still thank you
there's only first III yet know since
it's been closed to the public yeah ok
cool ah yeah yeah so it was for us we
did it and then Tim said oh we need to
get you on the show we do this game over
Gregory show podcast is like do you
think it could happen and am I probably
and then you'd already followed me back
in DME thanking me for promoting the
albums and then you immediately started
getting into twitch yeah oh he likes
video games this is easy or hell now we
still haven't talked but now we are
you're here now this doesn't count
yourself come to San Francisco I'll come
back come on Becky show will put you up
we'll treat you nice oh really yeah oh
that star oh yeah
John you fish w five star will give you
3 stars are new star hotels so first for
somebody who doesn't know you right how
do you describe yourself in a nutshell
um I'm the greatest rapper from Los
Angeles California ever exist and I also
stream on Twitch that's it basically
yeah modest too I know you're new to
humble mmm your humble [ __ ] you're new
to the game yeah what's your twitch
names Mercy's first there you go anymore
i say i stream on twitch and they do
this yeah i stream on twitch twitch TV /
murs twitter studies people love it they
love you too short right hey look it's
your first time out of the gate it's
hard to be shameless with yourself
emotion yeah me with which doc TV /
kinda funny game or kinda funny calm for
short you do that you do it yeah mom man
can we play together something sometimes
yeah somebody fuchsia multi player fans
I've been playing over watch every i did
a 24 hour stream my first 24-hour stream
I'm there I'm all about it good like the
one I've recently started getting into
it holy [ __ ] that game is fun what do
you play I play Winston all day every
mission to i've been with a Widowmaker
who is my perfect for the snipers yes
nyberg yeah dirty player yeah we on my
team which forever yeah you don't play
anything i know i play things like
overwatch i played for around was like
okay that's cute maybe with my cool
group yeah even burn do this yeah i'll
get in there i'll play some yeah right
what are you playing on Oh pc mmm are
you guys a console guys where I never
knew you're a huge dork murs haha
playing on your PC uh yeah oh I'm run
real man how many platinum trophies got
platinum trophy you finished that
persona 4 golden on Vita yet know Gotye
you laugh in my face about it murder God
dang so so what comes first for you that
video games are wrapping or music
rapping for sure I'm new I'm new to
video I play via guys when I was younger
yeah then I got a rap career and we
toured rappers they only want to play
madden
NBA 2k so I kind of like fell off yeah
and then my friend Todd like hook me up
with a pc is like you can play on Twitch
with your subscribers and it's like
playing with my friends right yeah and
it brings the fun back so i play with
overwatch with all my subscribers and we
have a great time I do a 24 hour stream
I get to play with all the people in New
Zealand or whatever fans from Germany
yeah those made was super cool and it
made me love gaming again because I'm
with people who actually played cool
games we played The Walking Dead
telltale series right we play cool [ __ ]
we don't play not the sports games
aren't cool but if I was that into
sports I just play them for real and I
don't want to do that no nobody wants to
be on no nobody one doing any three will
still play real sports am i right guy
yeah thumbs up oh yeah so now that
you're getting back into games you see
getting into your music more because
what I loved about have a nice life is
that there's a couple songs in there
that do reference games yeah yeah a lot
of gay Sega Genesis here or there so I
yeah when I'm playing now when I play a
game like for telltale i did a r.i.p lee
poem i do poems no you didn't yeah there
are a PP ly poem i did a poem called um
Dark Souls 3 as difficult as [ __ ] like
second I couldn't beat it so I played
till I died 316 times oh yeah so it took
me about 10 days of playing and I sucked
and it was very frustrating and then I
raged i staged the rage quit at the end
I smashed my controller and smashed
everything and then I made a poem so I
do poems about every every game we I
think we have a Minecraft poem we have a
telltale poem we have a Dark Souls 3
poems I'm gonna make an overwatch song
because I love it's my favorite game of
all time it's awesome except for jet
grind radio and all those radio there
yeah there you go come on then review
when you're writing music does it start
as a poem or is it always is different
for you yeah I start with a beaten and I
just didn't want to rap on twitch I
wanted to do something different sure
that it's hard to play the bead and get
clearance and I don't want to get my bod
muted and all the yeah yeah so I'll just
the spoken word and speak from the heart
because that's my you know video games
are in my heart i love you mercy watch
mine is like i love your album and then
I do every time I talk to you cooler oh
thank you I mean I except for the pc
part i can put that aside for now
he'll got to hook me up I'm gonna start
being on my ps4 a little bit do it you
gotta do that good good good good i play
first I'm ps4 laddie plate last of us no
yard was talking about last start with
last of us what about have you played on
a sharper did no I want to play all 40
then right that's what you got to do
that's for your stream you gotta play
get the nathan drake collection plate
through uncharted one two and three then
go straight to uncharted 4 there's a
vita game you don't need to play at the
video game all right you can skip that
one but uncharted all of them altar and
then was the last of the last of all i
heard about that yeah what about destiny
yeah man are you hearing the first
person shooters instead did you play
Division you tried to vision oh yeah
solana brutal people were take that [ __ ]
man serious man I want fighting about
anyway oh really yeah i'm not into I
don't want to like I just want to play
fun I want to have fun I don't want my
robbing or somebody won't stop that
means more of that then division is
because division gets you at the end
with the loot yeah buddy we'll check in
my career yeah dark the dark zone is
wait things like not like that you'd be
okay you'd be okay okay it definitely an
almost new content coming up you're
gonna be sitting pretty okay its first
on PlayStation he really likes
PlayStation it's kind of his thing I've
heard of it Oh get out of here when's
your next album was your next to her was
half I'm taking the year off and new
album next year I want to really get it
at which we've been going where to all
the other cons PAX East packs out
awesome honored to be here III so I just
want to get involved and show people I'm
really here to play and like be a
fixture in this community and took some
time off of wrapping and um yeah and i'm
doing a break in the Guinness Book of
World Records 24-hour wrap athan coming
hell yeah response to my by boost mobile
there you go feat you're gay oh now you
understand now you get how this is
working you gotta work with cunning
linguists again okay and all them ya
know who's got ya my boys they're out
here somewhere 33 no they're in la they
don't know I hear ya awesome yeah I've
our I'm we've crossed paths and I never
really got into their music until
recently haha they did it people grouch
and eligh those really amazed
yeah yeah I like them who do you like
that wraps aside from tech nine what
rich rich come on why Jesus why Jesus
come on everything what do you look like
a white cheese and say very much thank
you no that was another thing oh it was
the same exact thing where we went to a
tech show in petaluma on ocean and here
comes Ritz and I'm like who's this guy
look why Jesus and I'm like oh you're
really good ok same exact thing I took a
photo with him and he didn't no idea who
I was oh you matter whoa you got Twitter
fall yeah Oh what up though yeah what I
even like your hair that Taylor Swift oh
we can't with me okay I should work with
her I could there's this young up
intimately or like musically every way
he'll every way anyone possibly in the
next boyfriend that would be all the
next Calvin Harris I believe in you Wow
yeah yeah I like Taylor Swift I like
this up-and-comer rapper you've never
heard of called mega ramp oh yeah [ __ ]
never heard of that guy for her
interview you for ya now I never done a
bunch of songs of them about wrestling
yeah you've never worked with mega RAM
before no yeah and then Weezer I like
weezer have you heard of them what is
that they are enough knowledge oh hello
puppet coming band weezer okay i'll
check them out they're gonna be huge one
day yeah they're really hints yeah can I
get there I want Etsy or what yeah
probably yeah it'll get it coming a
little fan right into envelope yeah
etsy.com / Weezer hahaha no you're
talking of URLs we heard a song with
John Cena yes long time ago yes did you
actually meet him record that together
good friend of mine yeah really was
before he got super busy but yeah
probably the greatest human being I ever
met in my life really like I had to get
you 40 on it I invited one of the guys
from ICP he turned me down John Cena was
like yes and I'll come to South Central
and shoot the video dad John Cena in the
middle of South Central people were
jumping off of buses bloods crips cholos
like everybody's rushing him and he
signed every autograph he stayed there
for six hours crackheads taking pictures
like with all this jewelry on his watch
no security but he's huge he saw as big
as all there but probably he's scared at
all so when you when you look back and
talk about stuff like that and you've
been doing rapping for so long do you
feel like you've made it now like is
that like are you at a point where
you're like you look around like
this is what I've been working for well
there was a i mean when i got my
subscribe button for ww twitch TV /
murse nailed it yes i got it no then I
knew I made it no man every day it gets
crazier and crazier men home but uh yeah
I feel like I'm done I don't need I rap
when I ride with e 40 it was kind of
over from yeah like I can't really get
better than that no very a legend right
there yeah that's my favorite rapper in
life so after I've stopped trying to
prove myself to people that's awesome
yeah but um yeah man I think I'm pretty
established i'm here um you know q-tip
stop me walking down the back stage one
time and tell me what how much he love
my music that was like good lord i think
that was the moment I was like yeah like
YouTube feels like you're the [ __ ] it's
like shaking me and I'm like wow I grew
up on your music and you're really
excited to meet me weird yeah so my mom
might think I'm cool but who cares what
she thinks it matters you know your mom
mad like this I can disappoint my mom
whatever is long as I'm disappointed
long story for here for years yeah
that's that's good cause then you're
about to release you back into the wild
of e3 okay what do you want to see the
most I want to see this bat cave at
telltale i'm talking about i want is
like you put on your Instagram that was
kind of your stunning show off yeah i
want to go in there and okay whoopie pie
can make that happen for you really yeah
what do I have to do for you nothing
you've already done it you gave me an
amazing album called have a nice life
that you should go pick up represent
strange music get itunes you get
anywhere you want to steal it I don't
care anyone watching this show is savvy
enough to get it for free go ahead just
listen to it our people support people
that's what you need to know our people
support people you remember that we put
you at the end of one of the PS i love
you yes people went came out of the
woodwork to tell you how great that song
ya know really razon great track thank
you know yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna go
try to sneak in the tell-tale Batcave I
think okay and then we're gonna go to EA
play later a nice new battlefield two
titanfall about a foot one titanfall 2
yeah you know alright whatever that's
except right now Snoop Dogg see what
he's doing you know see what so easy to
boken weed while plays games on TV
nobody cares ya hui snoop dogg don't you
respect
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump no we're
gonna stop it nunim consume dog for
president can we get that that is the
that's the next thing is one of every
everybody loves running for president
yeah how about that yeah right row
fought for it like you versus kanya so
yeah or they should team up the same
ticket they've taken my god newbie West
can a dog would come on you dog be a dog
oh yeah alright cool birds you are an
absolute pleasure thank you guys lay
down by a cup Marissa's album have a
nice life right now make sure you go to
twitch TV / murders yeah he's doing it
and then follow him on Twitter was it
merton she's at MERS I'm yeah at Merce
where's 316 on snapchat and Instagram
all right game over Greggy that's me
game over Greggy all right murs go play
your games ladies and gentlemen there's
gonna be more from e3 2016 to make sure
you keep it here on gamespot com or
youtube.com slash kind of funny games
wherever you're watching this beautiful
content love you guys love you group hug
you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens